make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and
before we start this video I want to
pick your all's brain form it you know
sometimes I forget what I'm gonna talk
about when I start the video of like for
a brief moment and it's kind of funny I
crack myself up which I guess is kind of
necessary because I guess I'm the only
one who laughs at my jokes nobody else
does I'm not very funny put in any event
I'm currently doing a whole set up like
I'm RiRi doing the setup in the house
the new house in Columbus and I wanted
to pick your all's brain right this is
totally separate from from comments
explains for a whole different project
but I want to pick girls break this
first set up is the the two by two a two
foot by two foot soundproof panels which
are gonna be consistent uh and then the
benq monitor and then two Presonus
speakers this next setup is the exact
same thing except with a Bose sound bar
so let me know which one you guys like
right I mean I'm not gonna do both but
let me know which one you guys like I'm
kind of curious because I think it's
cool but in an event what's this thing
right there's this great big huge thing
that there was never explained in the
MCU I think it's the biggest thing in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe that was
never explained right like I think is
probably the biggest thing and it's the
most unique and interesting thing maybe
not unique but certainly the most
interesting thing we never found out
what Scarlet Witch showed Bruce Banner
and Avengers age of Ultron and I
remember thinking about that right like
I tweeted this out maybe three weeks ago
and that to me blew up right I got like
three thousand likes and I was like holy
cow like I guess I'm not the only one
who thought that was the case but I was
sitting there thinking about that and I
was like we never we never got an
explanation to that and at the time by
the time age of Ultron ended I was like
okay so maybe we'll get like a follow-up
an infinity war or in the game and then
both those movies came and went and we
still never got an explanation and maybe
was one of those things where it was
like well it's up to you to figure it
out it's like no it's up to you to tell
me is what it is it's like directors
that don't give you an ending to the
movie it's like well it's up to you to
figure out how the movie ends and is
your interpretation no is your job to
tell me because you're the filmmaker and
now I hate your movie because you didn't
give me an ending I'm looking at you
Coen brothers with No Country for Old
Men
so with this whole scenario it's
interesting right because the real
question is what did Scarlet Witch show
everyone and and it's kind of
interesting because on this surface it
kind of shows fears right it shows like
you know the things that everybody was
afraid of but I think it was really
more negative emotions right things that
people were afraid of or people
experiencing the worst memories of their
lives when you look at Captain America
for example
Captain America one never got that final
dance with Peggy Carter and to the the
idea or the interpretation among most
people who saw the movie was that
basically Captain America cannot live
without conflict he has to have a war in
order to have a purpose when you look at
Thor it was the idea that Thor was
basically gonna lead Ragnar he was gonna
lead Asgard the roof right his his
actions his power whatever the case was
was going to lead to the death and
destruction of everybody in Asgard when
he looked at Tony Stark it was the death
of his French right he was gonna get his
friends killed with with Scarlet Witch
it was a little bit different right
Scarlet Witch so pretty sure Rob meant
to say Scarlett Johansson instead of a
Scarlet Witch but through the wonders of
Adobe Premiere I can fix this right up
with with Scarlett Johansson it was a
little bit different right Scarlett
Johansson I really felt that was more of
like her reliving her worst experience
especially because of the fact that she
talks to Bruce Banner about the fact
that she can't have kids and probably
one of the most screwed up dialogues
ever and she's like I'm a monster you
know so like she she hates that that
idea and she was reliving the past in
that instance that we saw with Captain
America that didn't happen with Tony
Stark it didn't happen and with Thor it
didn't happen with Scarlett Johansson it
did right so she just kind of relived
her own past and it was like the worst
experience of her life but my question
is what did Banner see right because it
was Bruce Banner who was shown and then
he's flipping out and losing his mind as
as The Incredible Hulk and how do you
get from A to B right how do you get
from the point where he experiences
something and then goes on a rampage
after having experienced it and in my
mind because whatever it was it shook
him to his core right like it shook the
absolute hell out of a news it's like
sitting on the on the finger just shaken
you know just kind of losing his mind
when I think about this the first
thought initially went to something like
the death of Betty Ross no Betty Ross
dying or something along those lines and
then my thought process went to okay
well what if it's the opposite of what
the Incredible Hulk prides himself on
the most right like what's the one thing
the hope always says hopes strongest
there is right so like you know the idea
that like the hoax not the strongest
there is because he got absolutely
thrashed by Thanos so maybe that's what
he sees but I feel like neither of those
are significant enough to scare the Hulk
that bad because he reacted the only way
he could which was by being angry I
don't feel like either one of those
really like made the Hulk scared like
terrified him that
it may be that he experienced something
he like real you know we lived a moment
in his life but if the experience he had
in his life had screwed him up that bad
that it could push Banner into the state
where he loses his mind and becomes the
Incredible Hulk there's only one thing
that I can think of and that's the abuse
he suffered at the hands of Brian Banner
and given the fact that that Scarlet
Witch had kind of relived her own past
that stands to reason but it stands to
reason that a Scarlet Witch sits down
this is OK what I see is my time in the
Red Room basically Russia's version of
the Weapon X program essentially the
program that made Wolverine the Red Room
was essentially Russia's version of that
just like their winter guard is Russia's
version of the Avengers but if she
really relived her own past it makes
sense that Bruce Banner would experience
his own past - and if the abuse he
suffered at the hands of Brian banner
was so extreme that like it pushed him
to that point then is basically just
kind of like the Incredible Hulk lashing
out in that way but the Incredible Hulk
in the comics was a reaction to Brian
Banner right the idea of Bruce Banner
becoming the Hulk was because of all the
abuse he suffered and all that kind of
stuff
they're basically manifested in the form
of the Hulk when he was hit with all
that gamma radiation that was covered in
bill Mantlo in Peter David's run on the
Incredible Hulk which as far as I'm
aware is still a major focal point of
his character especially considering Al
Ewing's run on immoral Hulk and the one
below all manifesting as the the father
of Bruce right manifesting as Brian
banner to scare the piss out of it but
the fact remains here for me I really
kind of ally myself with somebody that I
response that I saw on the website Korra
right because I kind of googled this and
I was like well maybe I'm maybe I'm
missing so maybe maybe somebody else has
some really good answers out there
I don't over who was opposed to the
response in my editor can probably find
it but there was a response that said
that what Bruce Banner saw was losing
control like what do you saw was
basically the Incredible Hulk
going on a rampage and tearing
everything up and this kind of makes
sense right because me Incredible Hulk
as he's appeared in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe hasn't appeared in in the
variety of ways that he has in the
comics right in the comics you have all
different versions of The Incredible
Hulk you've got double Hulk Joe fix-it
Hulk Savage Hulk you've got like
mindless so you have all different
versions of the Incredible Hulk
I always thought savage and mindless
hope are really like two different
iterations like mindless Hulk was like
the idea from from the onslaught saga
and then like savage Hulk is like the
old-school right so I always saw it that
way I don't know many people see it
different but the idea was was you know
looking at that the Incredible Hulk as
you see him in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
it's usually for the most part just
chill right he's lucid so like he's the
whole
but like he knows what's going on right
like when he absolutely thrashes Loki he
calls him like a puny God right so he's
capable of speech and having
conversations and so on and so forth
he's not just a mindless beast the one
that we saw there was rampage in the
rampaging Hulk
that's savage for crime this is like
mindless savage war-cry just going going
on a going on a rampage and just tearing
things up but to kind of push him to
that extreme I think is really like
based on what we've seen The Incredible
Hulk and Bruce banners fear the Hulk
will loose control right like somebody
will happen somebody will pop off and
the Hulk will go nuts and I think that's
what he saw I think that what Bruce
Banner saw was the Hulk persona maybe
the death of Betty Ross something
triggering it and then him going on a
rampage essentially world war hulk but
not the world war hulk story from the
comics more of just kind of borrowing
the name and then like in the most
literal sense insofar as something
happens the Incredible Hulk goes nuts
and then like the Avengers try to calm
him down he ends up killing them all and
then like the world goes to war with the
Hulk and he's just like tearing
everything up he's killing innocent
people like he doesn't really care right
everything's just getting totally
destroyed and it's like the worst fear
of Banner not being able to wheel to
Hulk in and by extension the worst fear
of the Hulk because he's not a bad guy
right he's not no not a villain and even
in the comics he's not right he just
wants to be left the hell alone
the hoax got the most extreme case of
social anxiety in the history of the
world I just want to be left alone but
nonetheless I kind of thing that's what
it is but I think it's what it really
boils down to is the idea that what
Bruce Banner saw and I agree with this
post on Quora because they were the ones
it's not my idea they were the ones that
had it but I agree with the with the
notion that like Bruce Banner just saw
the Hulk losing control and it scared
the hell out of a Hulk to see what would
happen if he lost control and then he
ends up doing that anyway right so winds
up taking Tony Stark to bring him down
but I think it's a cool idea right
because what it does is it sets the
stage for things later on right like
what happens if the Hulk does lose
control right if he just totally loses
his mind I mean during the events of
Thor Ragnarok he was just having fun
there was him just kind of having a good
time but removed like the good time and
it's just like the Hulk rampaging and
just tearing things up and ripping
things apart I think that's what it was
like him killing the Avengers and then
the world goes to war with him and he
ends up basically killing the world I
think it would've been cool if it turned
out to be like a kind of hook the end so
like basically the world gets destroyed
the hooks the only one left or like she
saw himself becoming maestro that would
be awesome right like do if we got
maestro Hulk in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe that would be look
[ __ ] do reelect the beard and like the
hair and just like 15 times stronger
than the regular Hulk like dude during
the future imperfect storyline like
maestro broke the Hulk's neck it was
nuts like he literally like crippled the
dude dude he didn't even do it by a
little bit either like he absolutely
thrashed him right like The Incredible
Hulk goes toe-to-toe against monster
Hulk and gets rekt but that's kind of
the cool thing right because maestro
Hulk was interesting but he was also a
dick it was awesome
he was an amazing character anyway guys
let me know anything down in the
comments section I'm curious to know
what your all thoughts are if you guys
are new here to come as explained make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the robin core if you
guys enjoy this video make sure you drop
a like I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]